it's far harder working in the kitchen  with a blunt knife than it is with a  sharp knife the secret behind keeping a  sharp knife sharpen it before and every  time you use it first grip the steel  feel really comfortable about holding  the still imagine you're holding a  tennis racket now 45 degrees confident  grip this is the butt of the steel  really important to keep your fingers  behind there you never grip a steel with  your fingers over that because the knife  comes back in you've just lost a finger  always grip behind nice long strokes so  we get the whole of the blade  over Steel  stroke and we start from the bottom to  the top so there  cross there across slow Strokes over the  top of the steel and then come back  underneath then back in the knees  it is so dangerous working in the  kitchen with a blunt knife it caused so  much damage working with a sharp knife  is 10 times quicker more efficient  that's ready to start chopping